it's amazing to me that Avril Lavigne
when she was 16 years old writes
Breakaway and says gee I don't want to
sing that I'm going to give it to Kelly
Clarkson wait I gotta own something yeah
I like the song okay I'm gonna lead with
that but I'm gonna be honest with you my
label was like look if you do this we'll
give you this and so like with songs on
the record so I like the song I just
didn't feel like it fit in like if you
listen to the rest of that album it
doesn't sound anything like Breakaway
like really listen to Behind These
hazelizers since you've been gone or
because of you or walk away like all
those songs sound nothing like this Vibe
so I just didn't think it fit in and so
I'm gonna give the label this one they
were really like pushing for it and I
was like man if you all really believe
in it all right I like country music and
I actually feel like it's the most
country song I've ever heard from avrilo
it's actually a country song to me I
love country music but like I just
didn't feel like it fit in with the
record but yeah